doch wir den präsentiert forum bot
[Musik]
herr bundespräsident in der schweiz
demonstrationszug gekostet haben
deswegen die diktatur im iran will
verhandelt sie in ihr das wort mit
kaltes event revolutionen quad die armee
wird ihre juristischen umsturzversuch im
keim ersticken
[Musik]
der bundespräsident zürich schweizer
soldaten aufarbeiten und da gibt es eine
andere kantone verteilen grünen der
bundesrat duldet keine weiteren
demonstration am meer schweizers oder
auch zugriffe schweiz arbeiten mit
karabiner und bayonetta waren sie
eigentlich ein bürger ihre schuld grünen
[Musik]
herr bundespräsident glaube es bedingung
wurde ein arbeiter groß verschlechtert
sich reden
es ist schwierig die situation sie mir
damit spricht sie bedankt haben
[Musik]
durch das nicht hinkriegen
pikant
er hätte schließlich sieht
ob es nichts gesehen
der gestern nicht auf dem punkt
das doch gar nicht in die richtig
spielen sind
dieses zieht vom erster weltkrieg wo im
sommer unser viertes brauchen ist wo
millionen von soldaten mobilisiert wurde
sind und immer größeren verlust
verzeichnisse sind mit modernster
waffensystem sie die arminia aufeinander
los und der kriege statt boxen
[Musik]
als der krieg ausbrach trachten alle und
das lässt sich aus den erzählungen
vieler zeitzeugen leicht herleiten dass
es ein sehr kurzer krieg werden würden
[Musik]
als der krieg sich in die länge zieht
benötigen die ausländischen armeen
munition und material
die schweiz ist in der lage sei das zu
produzieren das führt zu einer
beachtlichen wirtschaftlichen
entwicklung und zu kriegs gewinnen die
zu jener zeit enorme ausmaße erreichen
die bevölkerung leidet unter der
rationierung und der lebensmittelkrise
und für die familien der mobilisierten
soldaten gibt es keine sozialhilfe so
vervielfachen sich das soziale elend und
die wirtschaftliche not und
militärischen leistungen finanziert
werden er blieb einfach weniger übrig
für genetik und konsum vor der
bevölkerung wenn sich der handel sehr
starkes bedürfnis ausgerichtet wird
verschärft sich das problem
[Musik]
der bfh hob auf die mission
wie war ihr besuch bei der
österreichischen armee so lala com ist
der beklagte sie sagen sie am brink noch
ein blindgänger österreich haben die
italiener von uns zurück
noch sind die deutschen der österreicher
überlegen noch
das sonntag erscheine optischer rein
militärische schweizer offiziere der hat
v6 oder italienischen oder französischen
front hat systems division scotland
ausgezeichnet bewährt aber das ist
eigentlich alles für seine defizite mehr
militärisch steigt hat der historiker
sicher ein scharfmacher einer auf
militärische gewalt und
gewaltbereitschaft auf militärischer
sieg ist erschreckend höchsten
opferzahlen serien schneidigen offizier
er hat demonstrieren
der streikende organisierten
arbeiterschaft eigentlichen quarzgang
radikaler fanatische offizier der nicht
viele skrupel hat mir viel mehr sorgen
bereitet sind diese hinter
nationalsozialisten dir frieden zur
strafe dann müssen wir uns auf alles
gefasst machen mongolei nach hier bei
uns ist vor allem dieser grimm ist ein
richtiger aufhetzen integrieren der re
linie islam colt exakt das
brandgefährlich
[Musik]
das vierte verlobte nancy shevell
korrekte grimm der berichtet die
aufrührer vom aktionskomitee aber kann
sich eine junge hübsche dame dadurch
wenig seele
gern
dieses jahr nach dem ja ich bin im
psychokrieg mit dr
lustig
der körper blinddarm operiert aber hat
der drv
irgendwas mache ziehen werden rund 70
mit dem bundespräsidenten
na dann
der milchpreis der arbeiter kongresses
basel hat beschlossen dass man die krise
wird in vielen schweizer familie muss
man sich drohungen und jetzt die 200 das
kommt die gefahr
[Musik]
als robert grimm das oltener
aktionskomitee gründete konzentrierte
sich ein teil der forderungen auf
ernährungsfragen
es ging um probleme im zusammenhang mit
preiserhöhungen ganz allgemein um preise
für milch und andere grundnahrungsmittel
[Musik]
land unterschiedliche lohnempfänger etwa
die hälfte des lohns für lebensmittel
ausgeben
rechnet man miete und kleider hinzu
kommt man etwa 75 bis 80 prozent seines
lohns durch eine aus garten hätte eine
inflation der vor praktisch unter
prozent mehr als verdoppelt auch wenn
schweiz nicht direkt im krieg integriert
ist sind soldaten mobilisiert die
soldaten kein richtiger lohn und
verdienen steuersatz dh drittel vor der
z1 militär bruch und damals noch bei
entschädigung gar für den militärdienst
dh ein drittel vom mio hansi der
reallohn wo schon niedrige sich nicht
man könne beziehen
das heißt es geht vorrangig für große
teile der bevölkerung nennt oder kostüme
lavita die anstieg der
lebenshaltungskosten des tetra stärker
im tessin
die bevölkerung nimmt das problem stark
war und ihre vertreter schreiben
deswegen der regierung
die botschaft beginnt mit den worten der
hunger klopft an die tür jeder test in
der familie die vom eigenen lohn lebt
die eine familie die hilfe gewebeprobe
solaria mit immer weniger reale
kaufkraft hand hat die bearbeitung
bevölkerung müsse versuchen immer dünner
werden die lebensmittel zu kaufen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
1917 gibt es immer mehr proteste die
sich in vielfältigen aktionen äußern
von demonstrationen bis zum streik
[Musik]
es werden protestmärsche organisiert
auch von frauengruppen gegen hohe preise
gegen lebensmittelknappheit relativ
frühe speisesäle trichter in basel in
zürich gc hat aarau den status
verbilligt kartoffeln ab sofort versucht
not lindern und notlage stark sie für
drei preise von vor drei tagen der
bevölkerung sie haben der caritasverband
[Musik]
naja wir aber jetzt dieser arbeiter
kongress der in basel haben sich der
einfachen grund wir von general stadt
befohlen worden ist und eine sehr
revolutionäre stimmung und eine
mitsprache ist dass das ist eine ausrede
am navi green und seine genossen planen
den umsturz den bürgerkrieg nicht
absolut ihre meinung
dieses schwächere verhalten des
bundesrats sagen wir können diese
revolution nur durch ein festes ja
geradezu brutales vorgehen verhindern
also meine worte kolonie wir brauchen
einen plan nicht erst wenn diese
revolution beginnt
[Musik]
der arbeiter kongress in basel war
tatsächlich eine wichtige etappe die
arbeiter bewegung plante nämlich die
aktionen der gewerkschaften und der
sozialdemokratischen partei besser zu
koordinieren
so wollte sie arbeitgeber und bundesrat
unter druck setzen und soziale
verbesserungen erreichen von einer
arbeiterin gefunden ist ganz klare zwei
drittel mehrheit gekippt und in der
schlussabstimmung ist ein sehr dunkler
hose
das ganz große mehrheit wieder 250 zu 4
stimmen verhandle
[Musik]
und diese oberst dem es gelingt sich
einzuschleusen versteht aber nicht ganz
was die arbeiterbewegung verraten was er
curtis ist eines ganz anders zählt vor
allem gehört da ist gebrochen die
revolutionären stimmung berichtet diesem
report des wifi direct produktions
gefahr dass er das auch bei produktion
er sagt zum beispiel man müsse sich auf
einen brutalen einsatz vorbereiten
es sei nötig entschieden vorzugehen und
zu versuchen die revolution zu
verhindern
und zwar bevor sie ausgebrochen sei man
müsse die anführer neutralisieren
gefangen nehmen und was das fußbad wann
es zu einer revolutionären aus das spart
wird sie wie sie medizinisch wir sind
mobilisiert ist und mit dem muster
konterrevolution jährige bürger schon
jetzt führe er tut das detailliert sich
aus danke
und da alles auftreten
selbstverständlich absolut ihre meinung
so konnten sich gegen steine werfende
aufführung wird infanterie ohne weiteres
schießen
gegen schießende aufführung ist in
ausgiebige maße von maschinengewehren
gebrauch zu machen
[Musik]
wir müssen diesem befehlsentwurf
augenblicklich im generalstab zukommen
lassen
es ist eine karikatur hüther das bewerte
ich aber natürlich verständlich wenn man
der masse star geworden hynix verschickt
wenn generalität und andre gierth ich
immer wieder fast durch filter große
rapid und nur noch ein kleiner teil vor
der realität sind und sorge vor der
arbeiter vor der arbeitenden bevölkerung
und das wirklich begangen ist eine
forderung und das bemühen von der
arbeiterbewegung sinnvolle formen vor
der interessen setzte jetzt finde das
ist ja völlig ausblendet der gott nur um
das militär richtig wichtig wird gegen
revolutionäre welche aus häusern feuer
sind handgranaten zu verwenden
nina wurde
wir haben hier noch viel zu tun
ja leider leider sehr wichtig
akio
[Musik]
wo waren wir stehen geblieben
bei den kölnern den handgranate gegen
stark besetzte häuser wissen
handgranaten und artillerie eingesetzt
werden das ist ja eigentlich die große
fehler nahm vor der planerischen
arbeiten bewegen nur dem grinch der idee
lag sie war bis überhaupt arzt z
sie sind immer davon ausgegangen es
würde dann zugestimmt die hand
eigentlich die organisierten arbeiter
und soldaten es in einer dosb
sie sind unter marktwert oder
4 jorge untersetzer somit erklärt ein
wahnsinn
genau und wie sozialdemokraten angereist
schluss mit dem was sie über die
zimmerwände konferenz gespielt
robert grimm jetzt erster versuch es
verhindere hat also die friedensbewegung
unterstützt und das brauche ich hätte
natürlich muss neu orientieren
er hält verordnet sich auch eine
revolutionäre strömungen abgearbeitet
wurden mit dem verein sind 10 mehr wald
im september nur 15
april liter 16v start von twitter
schwingt sondern untergrabe creme hätte
konferenz organisiert erwägen die regel
je größer mit russischen flüchtlingen
vor allem mit karl radek und einem
gewissen julian of genannt lenin der
damals einer der anführer der
sozialdemokratie russlands war das erste
mal versammeln sie sich in zimmerwald
unter höchster geheimhaltung
sie benutzten decknamen damit sie der
polizei nicht auffallen
sie lancieren einen aufruf zur
internationalen solidarität um den krieg
zu beenden
kriegsgegner sozialistisches
verschiedene landtag und zwar vorbei
zieht futter vor und die offizielle
sozialdemokratie von deutschland und
frankreich die anker wort mehr
miteinander geredet hingegen dort in
zimmerwald ist im robert krimmer
minderheit ströme für beide parteien zu
organisieren wo denn miteinander tötete
dort durch hätte damals ein riesiges
internationales prestige
bist du nicht an der neben gebiet wie
und
also
papier ist
der nationalrat hat sich damit als
country manager wort trifft aber so
richtig gekannt
ich mache ja der laut ihm ihre pläne in
der werra und in der schweiz oder des
buchs auf wunsch eine berlin ihr noch
die hand orange kann das raumgefühl und
bürger dann hat der länder wenn die
reise gehörte hatte gibt die katze an
dem er muss die kripo
sie sind meine gut informiert ich sage
nur eins der große linie erst wenn sie
mir glauben
wenn sie mich fragen
das ist ein völlig sehen
nakas gruppensieger und das hat man
schon gemerkt würde die schweiz gesehen
zu lenin hat diktatur des proletariats
wähler die muss erzwungen war der
wildnis bürgertum geht sie mit
privilegien nicht freiwillig ab robert
grimm ist eine sehr frühe and i could
also intakter von lenin orden der linien
hat eine welle der aktion ein
bewaffneter aufstand europa league vor
dem 8
[Musik]
und dann hat sich die situation
natürlich beschleunigt mit der großen
russischen revolution der sozialen und
politischen revolution in russland im
oktober 1917
[Musik]
duropack rim hält natürlich sehr für ihr
löst was in russland vor ort die mit
clark sieht dass das diktatorische
regime schocks und jetzt in russland bei
uns in dem porsche wie kredit- und
positiver tendenz es wird einen ansturm
die zukunft von russland in zukunft für
die friedliche revolution zu meiner
arbeit und basel beschlossen dass man
mit dem bundesrat raum
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie können die grünen wien sn
[Musik]
herr bundespräsident dort
doch ich hoffe dass treffer brachte zum
beispiel israel weiß dass viele familien
um kämpfer sind der bundesräte bietet
hilfe kam
und wenn jetzt löhnen wie bestiegen
herr bundespräsident ich muss sie
entweder dreijährigen priester hörig
wird milchzucker oder das aktionskomitee
rief zum genauen streik ruf gottes
weltkrieg müssen sie mal dass dieses
land bedeuten wird nein dass man
verhindern darum bin ich wohl der
bundespräsident zum wandel
wir starten das mit den revolutionären
kräften der kreis dem arbeiter kongress
basel dass der bursche weg russland
hd1000 dann haben wir einiges genauer
schlussresultat ausgerichtet damals 207
4 stimmen für verhandlung mit dem
bundesrat ganz einfach mal du schlag auf
den milchpreis zurück
wir verzichten generalstreik
gott
denn die das gesamtjahr
doch
[Musik]
man kann sagen dass kalender anfänglich
gesprächsbereit wirkt er versteht dass
die wirtschaftliche und soziale lage
schwierig ist es entsteht also ein
dialog zwischen dem bundespräsidenten
kalender und robert green
sie versuchen eine einvernehmliche
lösung zu finden
miteinander zu verhandeln diese erhöhung
wurde auf verschiedene schultern
verteilt es war also ein resultat im
sinne des oltener aktionskomitees ordner
aktionskomitee hat das thema aufgriff
und hat mit erfolg nach anne milchpreis
erhöhte schöne verhindere
also das ist sollten aktionskomitee wo
natürlich immer mit der ruhigen vom vom
generalstreik geschafft hat ist
erfolgreich
da stehen sie nach lassen sie das gut
bestückte die volkstänze mit der weg
bleibt noch bis nach busches jugendliche
wenn jetzt die zeit des
versammlungsverbots zu eurer bildung lee
ist arbeitet macht nach wanderungen im
bilde wird der platz vorstand zu einer
aktion aufrufen rüstet euch reserviert
den zehnten offenbar dass
unverschlüsselte aufruf zu einem umsturz
seit november startet jetzt ins klever
rat reservieren
november sowie eine kündigung von einer
revolution wenn man das liest man sagen
dass eine militärische führung sei
wichtig um die einführung zeigt
eigentlich wie die beweislage ist und
man hat einfach wenn er nur einen
empirischen beleg h in zürich ist es
gefahrenpotenzial dar
am gleichen abend hatte die 70 min
bundesrat stattgefunden wo mit unserem
zürcher regierungsrat und die notiz ist
irgendwie wieder belegt als beleg aus
kleid wurde man us in zürich händler
muss truppe dtb schicken
[Musik]
zum umsturz der kriminologe herum
herr bundespräsident und zwar vater grad
reagiert haben wirst du sofort wenn wir
jetzt mobilisiere denke wenn wir die
revolution im cramer stück geschichte
bedeutet 100 prozentig die mineralstoffe
bereits in detaillierter spa noch zählt
bundesrat wird das nötige veranlassen
herr bundespräsident sie können wir für
das nickel
nässe
was soll das jetzt stürmen
ich habe die aufgabe sie zu informieren
dass der bundesrat die armee mobilisiert
hat die geplante revolution wird
verhindert aber warum romans schuhcreme
die regierung hat uns befohlen euch
bolschewiki zu stoppen
[Musik]
also aktionskomitee ich völlig
überrascht sind sie hat nämlich da wo in
zürich truppen ii marschiert das hat sie
in bayern takt absolut möglich seit wir
wurden in ruhe stadium überrascht
sie hängt einfach nur noch möglichkeiten
akzeptieren sie das denn verlöre sie so
zeige das ganze prestige ihre
verhandlungsposition weil sich so bis
lotte blütezeit dass er eigentlich nie
zeit erhält
[Applaus]
ganz tagen in kassel heute zu bauen
auch nicht aus
brot und danke
das sind die büros oder weniger stand
verschlossen
der bundesrat hatte die revolution blieb
aber hat auch den vorschlag akzeptiert
und war offensichtlich ein scharfmacher
dem rücksitz vergangen sind siege
maligen volkswirt 15 hätte schon geht's
warum der liga ist vom bundesrat ja was
lernen wir jetzt machen schweizerischen
befristet aber trotzdem schuss vor den
bug für den bundesrat
[Musik]
ich hoffe einfach dass das ganze familie
gehen
man hat alles gestanden ist
[Musik]
dabei hängt sich wenn der zeiger sind
sinkt dramatisch erzählen welle auch
einen bevölkerte damit garten mit dem
freund gar keine so eine übermacht
könnte irgendwo office stellen lecker
man muss auch sehen dass sich das
visuelle bild die infanterie trug einen
star ellen der wurde damals neu
eingeführt die absicht war dass er angst
einflößen sollte eigentlich in der erste
ort wo man sich eine bessere filme sehr
schlimme zeit aber in der steht dass
natürlich einen ganzen volk tief lösen
und bau schreckensbilder das
maschinengewehr ist natürlich auch
symbol und und hat eine unermüdlichkeit
oder square maschinell straße und das
hat dann schon natürlich einen
martialischen eindruck
[Musik]
robert deutschland handelt die
sozialistische klasse macht übernommen
haben
dank der pflege ist so gut angehört der
arbeiterklasse gemacht habe ich nicht
möglich sei
[Musik]
am 30 oktober 1918 verweigern sich die
matrosen von kiel einem befehl des
oberkommandos der marine
der besagte sie müssten england
englische schief ergreifen diesem 3
diese lokalen revolution verbreitete
sich wie ein lauffeuer im restlichen
deutschland
es folgte ein aufstand in bayern
hauptsächlich in münchen
die soldaten und die arbeiterräte
griffen in münchen die macht und riefen
eine sozialistische republik aus also in
der nachbarregion da franz und am 19
november erreichen die streik bewegungen
in der region berlin ihren höhepunkt mit
einem massenstreik in der stadt berlin
dieser streit führt zur abdankung von
kaiser wilhelm der zeit
[Musik]
republik wie in deutschland aus größer
vor der spd
das heißt wir haben also große wandel
europa ist im umbruch
[Musik]
die beiden großmächte der epoche
deutschland und russland brechen
zusammen
russland 1917 mit der revolution die den
zaun stürzt und dann mit der
oktoberrevolution der bolschewiken die
von lenin angeführt wird
wenn sich ein paar gerät ist von der
waffe gebrauch zu machen habe einen
kritische zustand der in zürich zu
befehlen aber doch noch für das wettbüro
es ist soweit bewaffneter aufstand
veranlassten sie sofort alles notwendige
und bringe die plakat zum zu mehr als
büro
[Musik]
frau münsterplatz handke sich versammelt
die bevölkerung die streikenden sie hat
eigentlich ist ihnen verboten wurde vom
braker sich zu versammeln
[Musik]
das neue besonders wenn er sage dass wir
den starken unterzahl sind aber
tatsächlich bemüht während im moment
nummer 552 bereitschaft raumstation iss
im fall der zugang ist er schwul ist
kompliziert ausgerechnet jetzt
die spanische grippe wo dort in der zeit
vom ende vom erste werke ganz europa
erfasst hat ist eine ganz schlimme
krippe mit vielen todesfalls sie weiß
wie komme davon aus dass bis zu 420
millionen einige sechziger bis zu 50
millionen menschen sind in der schweiz
grippe nimmt man aber 25 musik durch die
verursachten arme herzt also dass sony
tätig überforderung city hat deutlich
größere bus reagiere privatbesitz sind
dann oft lazarett zur verfügung gestellt
wird also die erhoben dort verliebte
opfern haben ruft die turnhalle täter
selbst zurückziehen auf ein verfahren
zur absetzung demonstration auflösen
revier
so und die hängen wir jetzt an jeder
ecke dieser stadt ist ja klar ohne
wecker es wertet handgranate ich selbst
wenn du diese lizenz gewährt
wir müssen uns auf den häuserkampf
vorbereiten süße com sind schwerhörig
so und jetzt ab sofort zu befehlen
machen natürlich mit der visa com public
mit 50 soldaten löse das ist allgemein
bekannter furchtbar viel größere masse
sei denn man will sie zum messias hat
aktiv sind hier dann die bevölkerung
marschiert und hand nach befehl von
blüten als warnschuss in die luft schoss
es hat der bauer verletzt durch
querschläger und es hätte tote soldat
erschoss man weiß aber nicht genau woher
der schuss komisch meine damals seid
könnt nicht eine sie vom militär selber
aber man muss ich eine klage sieht
damals hin zu untersuchen
vor allem wenn es mich das militär keine
sehr musik durchgeführt wurde
der bundespräsident er schlägt diese
demonstration acht nehmen nur ist die
kasse einer zuschrift ein landesweiter
generalstreik können ärgerte sie
entweder verhandelt und er das wort mit
kalt das event revolution mit gewalt die
armee wird juristischen umsturzversuch
im keim ersticken
herr bundespräsident in zürich schweizer
soldaten beide und da gibt versteht
diese besondere karten verteilen können
der bundesrat könne wieder
demonstrationen jesus haben wir doppelt
zustand wie in russland schweiz oder
auch der schweiz arbeiten mit kabinen
und bei und da waren sie eigentlich ein
bürgerschreck ihre schuld gründe werden
es ein paar testing friedlich der
bundesrat wird jede weitere
demonstration auflösen
er ist leicht spott
stow
[Musik]
schlecht wird entscheidet die gesichter
statt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
er ist für figuren ausgezeichnete
agitatorischen argumentationen wo immer
marxistisch hinter leid sind sehr sehr
dominierend ein sehr entschiedene
arbeiterführer sie autoritär auch
charismatisch robert green hat sich dann
keine luft schwingen zum vertreter sowie
einige vertreter der sozialdemokraten
gegenüber im bundesrat
[Musik]
einfach nicht akzeptieren aber
generalstreik kannst du nur dort hören
dass wir hand gar keine andere wahl
generalstreik im ganzen land dann ist
für die creme clark sie jetzt war mir
niemand wirklich gibt die bewegungen der
hand hat
das sind in zürich einfach lokal sich
entwickelt und auch gegenüber dem
bundesrat
es bliebe dann muss man jetzt zu mitteln
vom landes generalstreik
tippen sie die zürcher arbeiter union
setzte ihn unter druck weil sie sagte
wir beginnen mit dem generalstreik grimm
und die führung des altonaer komitees
hatten das problem wenn sie nichts taten
riskierten sie die kontrolle zu
verlieren
die chinesen schon mal ganz locker und
leicht mit dem streik die sind sicher
wieder dabei war
dort ist ja keine maschine hätten streik
stand seit zwei wochen
und was ich mich im august du kannst
situation dass über die schweizer sind
jetzt appelliert bitte weiter
ich habe mir hatten hier mit don ist und
du hast doch gesagt jahrelang in
frankreich gestimmt
gut dann braucht man einen
forderungskatalog für die generalstreik
das wichtigste ich dachte ich jetzt
stundenbuch und unbedingt unbedingt
alters und hinterbliebenen versicherte
und als traum stimmrechte ja sowas und
mir verlangen dass proporzwahl weg führt
wird niemand amtlichen parlament so
betraten sie es verdient hat
der generalstreik ist zum großen teil
improvisiert improvisator der vor tricks
katalog ist tatsächlich zum leben pro
visiert sie es sind froh kukksi war
damals einfach so auf der hand gelegen
sind
der büro
ich habe gerade eine meldung erhalten
von unseren nachrichtendienst
deutschland und österreich haben
kapituliert
[Musik]
jetzt ist alles verloren
es bricht doch die revolution aus die
wollte wie kann jetzt gnade uns gott
creme und seine genossen wollen wir uns
das gleiche was sehen sie
zum glück sind wir gewappnet
deutschlands zusammenbruch ist
katastrophal für diese offiziere die
nach preußischem vorbild geformt sind
mit dem beträchtlichen prestige
deutschlands im hintergrund darum
ergreifen sie eine reihe von maßnahmen
um die revolutionäre ansteckung der
schweiz zu verhindern
elite die han alle irgendwann einmal in
deutschland studiert also da gibt es
intensive aus durch musst du und was
passiert ist es dass es kettenreaktion
geht man weiß was in russland passiert
ist und das in deutschland nun auch als
sozialistisches regie im ennstal die
militärische 4 1 größtes jetzt
abgelaufen uns an die vom krieg heißt
für militärische 4 in der regel zog in
kasernen und alltag und nicht mehr vor
vor großer macht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kamerad pressetext.de lust hätte und ich
sage ich gern die sophie das verwendete
werner moser fachdisziplinen
[Musik]
und in der romandie ist der kontext
etwas anders denn hier freut man sich
sehr über das kriegsende und die
unterzeichnung des waffenstillstands am
11 november 1918
[Musik]
man ist also nicht auf protest untere
wollte eingestimmt in der romandie
herrschte eine frankreich zuneigung die
im laufe des ersten weltkriegs immer
bedeutender
der sieg der französischen armee 1918
hat diese zuneigung noch verstärkt im
november 1918 wollte man deshalb das
kriegsende feiern und sich nicht einer
protestbewegung anschliessen
das altenaer komitee wurde in der
romandie verspottet als altena schwaben
sowjet also etwas das zugleich mit der
russischen revolution und mit der
deutschen revolution zu tun hat etwas
das es abzulehnen galt
siegburg bei köln belegte passiv also
also heute show präsentiert die
manifesta den pazifik wurde mir gesagt
kameraden äppelallee greve sinnieren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
denn hunde eine und lies einfach es ist
ganz prestige und zeit jetzt ist aber
moment wenn ihr nicht könnt darüber
diskutiert als ein job sondern jetzt
geht es darum wer etwas im lande
strohhalm der bürgerliche regierung so
ein rehbock machen dass mir die vorträge
an der seite von vornherein es ist wahr
dass wurde nur knapp akzeptiert weil
gewisse leute nicht anwesend waren
und weil das militär mobilisiert worden
war und den bahnhof lausanne besetzte
das ist nun vielleicht etwas anekdotisch
aber der bahnhofsvorstand wurde
angeblich aufgefordert sein büro zu
räumen und das soll ihn schließlich dazu
bewogen haben im namen der eisenbahner
den generalstreik anzunehmen
[Musik]
die schweizer sozialisten von die
revolution des proletariats auch zu uns
bringen war dann ins register
[Musik]
ist in zeiten wie diesen nicht genug
denn
ob sie es
[Musik]
er ist als meinhof für deutsches kino
robbie ich habe ich mich impfen ein
telegramm vor der großen reise wirklich
zurücktrete
[Musik]
kaiser karl der erste von österreich
zurückgetreten lang lebe der
internationale sozialismus die dynamik
muss nicht sein
mit dem generalstreik kann man für immer
für andere musste also gehört was der
kreis auch österreich ist das ausbauziel
gehören vielleicht und wie sie lausanne
kaum da steht uns einfach machen wunder
die walter knoll branche
[Musik]
die eisenbahner spielten beim
generalstreik eine sehr wichtige rolle
allein schon deswegen weil sie die
städtischen zentren mit den ländlichen
gegenden verbinden konnten
so konnten sich die ideen verbreiten was
einen umfassenderen streik ermöglichte
sie haben sich engagiert und das ist
natürlich ein wichtiger faktor um größte
teil foto industrieproduktion bellinzona
in bellinzona beginnt der streit sofort
und er beginnt dank einer person
giuseppe simona der vom streiken der
deutschschweiz erfährt er fährt mit dem
velo von airolo nach bellinzona von
bahnhof zu bahnhof und informiert sofort
beginnen alle bahnarbeiter zu streiken
von lopez bellinzona man streikte und es
vor kein zug mehr
das bedeutete im grunde dass die
arbeitnehmer die in den vororten oder
weiter weg wohnten also nicht im
stadtzentrum nicht zur arbeit fahren
konnten
es war unmöglich irgendwo hinzufahren
das gab dem protest den charakter eines
generalstreiks auch wenn das zentrum in
der deutschschweiz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die libysche arbeiter quartiere waren
von der armee besetzt man sieht dass ein
bürgerkriegs klima in zürich zusätzlich
sehr heftig sie da mehr hätte ich dort
massiv vierte maschine quer kavallerie
in den beiden städten zürich und basel
herrschte eine atmosphäre fast wie
während einer militärischen besetzung
jegliche arbeiter versammlungen waren
verboten
also eine halbe militärische besetzung
oder eine halbe diktatur wenn man so
will
wer mit bild.de vor dem generalstreiks
geht ja nicht so furchtbar viel
dann sehen wir immer arbeiten im
sonntagsanzug und schön geordnet laufe
es ist es so streikleitungen de maistre
ort haben versucht möglichst die
disziplin durchsetzen vor allem sie
sofort einig das war das zieht vom
streik kein alkohol ausgeschenkt werden
[Musik]
das ist der märz können
aber
[Musik]
das parlament die berufe wurde auf
anordnung vom bundesrat je 200
parlamentarier hat sich in bayern
treffer darunter die damalige 220
sozialdemokrat das heißt mitglieder von
der aktionskomitee sie herrn nationalrat
haben mit ihrem generalstreik unser land
in eine schwierige lage gebracht
seit langem versuchen grube lose hetzen
und anhänge des bolschewistischen
terrors in der schweiz den boden für
aufrührerische bewegungen vor zu beenden
mit dem generalstreik aber hat die
erregung einen solchen grad erreicht
dass der bundesrat zur aufrechterhaltung
von ruhe und ordnung vier infanterie
regiment und vier kavallerie brigade
mobilisieren müssen wir lassen uns nicht
erpressen
[Musik]
gott schütze und schweizer aus
ich gestehe ihnen ein bundespräsident
meine herren jawohl wir sozialdemokraten
sind revolutionäre es gibt revolutionen
mit einem friedlichen verlauf
was die mittel der revolutionären
umwälzung betrifft so hängen sie nie und
nimmer von der aufstrebenden klasse auf
sie sehen bedingt durch die herrschende
klasse selber durch die friedliche
revolution noch mal zu können ich habe
hier ein telegramm abgefangen von
unserem nachrichtendienstler inhalte
nachricht lautet wie folgt an das volks
kommissariat der sowjet republik
russlands und so gruß und glückwunsch
dem jahrestag der sozialistischen
revolution das proletariat der ganzen
welt erhebt sich gegen den plan der
imperialisten das sozialistische
russland zu erdrosseln mitbruder groß
die sozialdemokratische partei der
schweiz ist das ausdruck eine
gewaltfreie bewegung nationaler sie
erklären
der generalstreik sei ein verbrechen
aber wir sind der auffassung ein
verbrechen ist es wenn man die armee auf
das eigene volk loslässt
sie sagen der generalstreik sei ein
gewalt mittel da sind in unserer
arbeiter bewaffnet haben sie
maschinengewehre die idee der revolution
existierte nicht in der schweiz
ich glaube es war lenin der sagte die
schweiz sei kein land der revolutionen
sondern eins der sitzungen und
organisationen
es hatte einen oder zwei glas gegeben
aber das lässt sich nicht mit den
konfrontationen vergleichen denen andere
länder zu jener zeit ausgesetzt waren
etwa italien russland deutschland
frankreich
wir wollen die 48 stunden woche und mehr
demokratische rechte demokratische recht
ein nationaler ein generalstreik ist
eine erpressung muss wieder presse geben
entweder als gestohlen was meinen sie
mit 24 stunden als und die wartung
verordnung für unsere streiks mobil
machen der generalstreik richtig einzig
mögliche antwort auf die armee
provokation und 4 12 stunden vor bis und
loni sie und das aktionskomitee in
corpore fragt das war ein bürgerkrieg
ein bundespräsident sein sie ganz als
verantwortlicher nationalrat will
gut
dass sie sicher eine sehr emotionale
debatte sie versichert umgang
diskutieren
schiers tommy wirklich folgsamer mit der
vorzeige der grünen hätte einfach bis am
schluss noch oft mit einem showdown
vermeide
doch die bürgerlich meiner meinung nach
war es der bundesrat der die
konfrontation suchte er dachte die
situation verschlechtere sich zusehends
man liegt die große befürchtungen
angesichts der ereignisse in deutschland
und österreich
ich glaube sie haben die konfrontation
gesucht
ab einem gewissen punkt wollten sie
diese
und wie gut man sowieso gott und das
blutbad ist
was ist schon in der mache
[Musik]
ich glaub du musst deine rausch 31 tote
gebe es gewisse
[Musik]
er hat sie für josef huber stehen sie
eine genaueste büro genauso sehen sie
sofort merkt auch dass sie in
vertreterversammlung dass die leute froh
fällig so wie es interessiert nur 14 der
streik vorgesetzten abkochen
sie läutet mir sofort wenn der entscheid
falsch verstanden verstanden übrigens
die woche noch gut weil sie beim
telefonieren der lage sind ihre hatte
irgendwann keine ist ja genau der krise
wird teurer wenn der streik wie gott und
der krise wird billiger in der
streikwoche wird bedeutete da krise
teurer wenn der wettergott und kreise
billiger über den abbruch wird
verstanden doch ein paar bürger genauso
wirken
[Musik]
ich glaube unser telefon funktioniert
mich nie vor der tür steht wahrte mit
aufgesetzter bajonett
der züchter und isolieren das hat
natürlich zur militärische vorgehen
gehört dass man nachrichtendienst
betrieb blüht infiltrieren
ich bin gegner möglichst schnell und das
habe ich dann gemacht die den jungen
offizieren ist ein junger offizier jetzt
platzieren lassen
armee und die herrschende klasse wenn
dies damit dass mir ich sie nicht
abbrechen aber mit der sozialist macht
jetzt werde von russland russland nicht
mit dem spiel zufrieden wir waren keine
bewaffneten aufstand wir waren keine
blösse
wir müssen jetzt entscheiden wieder
machen oder aufgabe bedeutet zwar einen
gesichtsverlust aber unter der von uns
da nichts vormachen weitermachen
der bürgerkrieg es blutbad
bewaffnete soldaten gegen unbewaffnete
arbeit frauen kind
wenn wir das wirklich
gott ist größer das zu
wenn wir seit spitze strand vom büro
gestanden
so haben wir sozusagen im großen bild
die linke auf eine mögliche täterschaft
das ist ein wenig links und mir meine
technik in der wirklichen wandel will
nur suchen wir unsere regierung gestürzt
sind und die vorträge der sätze das
hätte ich sozialdemokrat linie zog sie
aber im moment situativ wo jetzt die
kräfte so herper voneinander prallten
aufeinander prallen
die kann man schon sagen moment gäbe
mögliche export- gestanden
also stimmen ab wer ist wieder abbruch
vom streik
werde ich für portugal
der fall ist klar streik widerspruch
einlegen
was soll das warum stimmt fortsetzen
sogar von bürgern geredet
der saal brechend und herr chris sie hat
am schluss dann doch für twitter führung
vom streik gestimmt obwohl gedreht hat
aber es gibt eine mehrheit für den
abbruch er hat für sich persönlich neu
trainer ziege steht als das hat jetzt
der streik abbruch dass das nötig ist
und das ärgert über den bundesrat dass
es mir möglich straße dietrich
fertigstellen
der grimmig gewiefte taktikfuchs sich
bewusst dass der streik abbruch ohne
konzession von der gegenseite als
kapitale kapitulation der arbeiterschaft
interpretiert wird
und da sind dann natürlich als
streikführer messe vermieter ich vermute
dass sich damit das gehalt das er denn
wenn er vor
oft werden arbeiterstadt bessere
position hat arbeiterschaft gefunden
schmählich nachgebe vor der bundesrat
zur geständnis gemacht habe und
allgemein ich das als niederlage
empfunden wurde sei denn es war eine
niederlage weil sie kapituliert haben
der bundesrat hat gesagt recht den
streik ab und sie haben den streik
abgebrochen
der erste eindruck die erste bilanz also
eine niederlage
sein scheck
hallo
sind sie sich alle wege
roger quaderer nachdem boy
nicht fortgesetzt
halo reach
zwar sei dank hat fertig machen
dadurch droht die arbeiterin grant
erschossen
was aber die streichliste vbs hat jetzt
genau das kann kann auch interessenten
sollen wir machen kompromisse vom land
ins gesicht und das ist jetzt dank
armee und bürgertum wie immer unter
einer dicken fehler gemacht aber die
braucht mehr informationen
[Musik]
franke ist generalstreik relativ heftig
durchgeführt wurde
man hat diese bahnstrecke gesperrt mit
großer stein mit schwerer und dann ist
das was patron nach gaza geschickt wurde
wenn man hat unbedingt wähle dass züge
wieder fahren und dann kunst summe
überall der einsatz von militär die idee
befindlicher reagieren auf die
aufforderung sich zu bewegen und wächst
und dann wird für eröffnet und führt zu
drei doppel
[Musik]
so ist die vision eine meldung aus
grenchen drei demonstranten erschossen
von welche soldaten des jägerbataillons
heute nachmittag eine spontane
demonstration unsere truppen haben sich
aufgelöst eigene verluste sehr guten
übermitteln sie allen beteiligten
meine glückwünsche der befehl auch nach
streik abbruch jede ansammlung ist zu
verhindern
wir wollen keine
politische revolution
wer so
heiliger
jetzt wird links solch guten weg
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wilson trägt sehr stark unter dem
einfluss verbunden extra hat immer
wähler möglichst schneidig und autoritär
auftraten oben zement ausgefallen
[Musik]
die eisenbahner bezahlten für ihren
streik einen hohen preis viele verloren
ihre arbeit
über 3 sieg für fahrwerke krise bauen
noch abfangen
fehler wurden verurteilt den mitgliedern
des olfener komitees wurden ebenfalls
gefängnisstrafen aufgebrummt
togo bei creme die ich zu sechs monate
haft verurteilt worden
[Musik]
nach dem abbruch vom streik ist
wichtigen exponenten sowohl vor der
unternehmer als auch vom staat praxis
machen wenn es andere welle sich
absehbar dass dolan unruhe herrsche wird
und was der generalstreik auf südlich
und auflösung politischer ebene markiert
ist dass wir nicht ganz sie schichten
der gesellschaft
stamm demokratischer spiel und sicherte
das bestimmt die form von umgang mit der
arbeiter bewegt insbesondere wenn man
sich einfach militaristische strategien
verloren schlecht funktioniert sind zwar
wunder aber es war basierende noch was
ist da los
obwohl das bürgertum vor einer
revolution angst hat suchte es dann nach
dem generalstreik das gespräch mit den
gewerkschaften
das sollte streiks und konfrontationen
verhindern
es herrschte also eher eine kultur des
konsens als der konfrontation
[Musik]
in den folgenden wochen
ich betone hier wochen treten fast
überall arbeitgeber mit arbeitnehmern in
verhandlung und vereinbaren lohnerhöhung
sie können die gesamte geschichte der
schweiz von 1848 bis heute studieren die
songs wurden solche lohnerhöhungen
gewährt
der gott der radikale reduktion von der
arbeitszeit stattgefunden man sich die
wichtigsten reduktion von a bis z was in
der sicherheit von 59 stunden ungefähr
auf 48 also elf stunden weniger pro
woche
es gibt einen rasanten zuwachs an
tarifverträgen die nach dem ersten
weltkrieg unterzeichnet werden vor juni
verbindliche verhandlungen zwischen
arbeitgebern isa zion und gewerkschaften
nach dem generalstreik finde so einige
verhandlungen ständig statt und es war
david gehen die abkommen geschlossen
im wahllokal gesamtarbeitsvertrag auf
ganz gesamtschweiz geschriebene
geschlossen
ich bezeichne der generalstreik im sind
es demokratisches ereignis sie den
versuch sie vor der organisierten
arbeiten bewältigt sich von der straße
her ist freundlich spiel zurückbringen
[Musik]
genossen wir leben in einer zeit großer
gefahren in deutschland hat adolf hitler
die macht an sich gerissen
das deutsche parlament steht in flammen
unsere freiheit steht auf dem spiel
in italien durch mussolini in
deutschland durch hitler
nun müssen wir ins auge fassen was für
uns als sozialdemokraten bisher
undenkbar war
denn hitlers und mussolinis
gesinnungsgenossen sind auch bei uns
aktiv
[Applaus]
und dabei halluzinationen und 19 wollen
sehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das referent ist wenn der kommt egal
[Applaus]
[Musik]
perfekter
wir müssen dieser juden und insbesondere
die sehr jung marxisten bekämpfen
das bösartige gift verspritzt in kleine
dose ja täglich verspritzt in kleinen
dosen kann nicht durch verfassung und
gesetz bekämpfte haben
[Musik]
der engel sondern durch und durch ein
militärisches ist generalstabschef wurde
dann das ich mir aber daraus meditel
verwaltungsmäßig viel zu wenig schnell
gegangen hat ganz andere vorstellungen
hatte früher den 20er jahren und nach
habe er hat immer noch das große gefahr
potenzial von von der kommunistischen
revolution das hat ihn und triebe und
wer soll das militär schweren traktor
und das hat ihn da nicht möglich von der
front geführt
der emi sonntäglich in der diskussion
eine führende front ist xi in der
schweizerische ganze große figur im
rechtsextremismus sie hat jede karte hat
kampfschrift entworfen hat sportschuhe
ordnung im staate das ist alles sehr
sehr rechtsradikal formuliert sie und
hat dann versucht autos gedankengut die
fronten organisation jetzt bringen
ob es die visionäre sonderegger
der
gegen uns antraten einsetzen wollte
[Musik]
wenn sich jetzt
landes fühle
ja erinnerst du dich noch an diesen
wunderschönen tag damals in rom weiß er
diese leidenschaft fertige heimat
atemberaubend
nur ca
[Musik]
jetzt hat die stadt
was ist passiert
probert
wie sowie stühle den weg
[Musik]
ich hoffe jetzt eine stunde neben den
rausch trinken
genossen sozialdemokraten genosse green
ist krank er hat nicht gebeten seine
rede hier aber seine worte seine worte
sind auch meine worte haben heute eine
richtige entscheidung zu fällen der 918
unseren generalstreik unterdrückt jetzt
hat sich die situation dramatisch
verändert im norden haben wir hätten im
süden mussolini genossen
im ring ist gekommen unser land gegen
faschistische gewaltanwendung zu
verteidigen demokratie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
china präsentiert wurde wo honda jazz